I had to just finish the first year of
work at an investment firm and received
my first performance review it was bad
note I am humbly telling you it was bad
so I don't brag my reviewer actually
admitted he had to inflate my scores a
little bit so he didn't look so horrible
that level of that my Amir's reaction I
am too stupid to make it in investing my
next reaction I have to punish myself
for my failure I left the office and
began sprinting through a still chilly
Boston night I hate running
I don't ever run for exercise but every
time I felt I need to punish myself I
would sprint and then my lungs began to
burn I had failed and the voice in my
head said you should suffer for it if a
friend came to me upset about a bad
performance review or a terrible fight I
wouldn't tell her to go run some laps as
a punishment I would hug her and help
her figure out a way out of this
difficult time
so why would I treat myself differently
than I would a close friend think of the
voice you used to criticize yourself
that interview was so horrible why
couldn't I come up with better answers
or I said the dumbest things on that
date I'll be single forever
we've internalized this negative
self-talk as normal we aren't even aware
of it and we don't question it
this voice gives us feedback on our
performance we believe it makes us be
better try harder reach higher
it's our internal code but its feedback
from a coach who doesn't really know how
to coach
research shows that athletes are more
motivated by positive cultures than
hostile ones yet when it comes to
coaching ourselves we tend to be more
hostile than positive I thought I was
becoming tougher by punishing myself for
my failures but the opposite was true if
I wanted to be a great coach to myself
and improve my performance I needed to
train that voice in my head - shush
negative self-talk and embrace self
compassion instead self compassion is a
switch from self judgment to self
kindness it's firing the coach who says
you are so weak and hiring the one who
says I understand it's tough when your
team is getting blown out at halftime
you don't win the game by screaming you
suck
coach Kade the legendary Duke basketball
coach with the most wins in division 1
men's basketball history says that his
most reliable pep talk to his players is
I believe in you the positive impact of
self-compassion is rooted in biology
when we are hard on ourselves our body
doesn't realize that it's our self-talk
and not someone else yelling at us and
releases stress hormones when you stew
on that problem or beat yourself up over
that failure your body continues to
release cortisol diverting energy from a
task at hand that's why if you are a
basketball player and you miss the first
free throw
you don't improve your chances of making
the next one by beating yourself up you
do it by taking a deep breath and
concentrating as one of the greatest
poets of our generation Taylor Swift
fill this you need to just shake it off
last week I cut myself thinking I am not
strong enough to give this talk I have
too much going on it's going to be so
bad I am at this appointment but that's
a lie I am strong enough but it's not
about strength I was drunk on cortisol
and I needed to get my head back in the
game so how do they do it
four years ago I wouldn't have I would
have kept beating myself up all the way
to a very mediocre draft in the turbo
self-fulfilling prophecy today when I
realize I'm being myself up I bring up
my inner scotch K who says I believe in
you and I go through five steps of self
compassion first name it mean what it is
that you're actually feeling I wasn't
just stressed I was hurting because with
everything else going on with my
life I didn't feel I had capacity to do
justice to a topic that matters so much
to me need to first understand exactly
what's wrong step 2
feel it allow yourself to fully embrace
that feeling whether it's upset or anger
or disappointment I was hurting and I
wanted to cry it's high did I didn't go
for a sprint I took a walk and I cried
if here's a go have felt crazy doing
that it's actually a natural human
reaction
it's my tree old nice Lenna throwing a
tantrum
then suddenly stopping and getting back
to play the secret here is once you
allow yourself to deeply feel that
feeling that negative emotion passes
faster step 3
is my favorite comfort yourself ask
yourself what would you say and do if it
was a friend and as yourself what do I
need right now to feel better I came
back home from my walk I played the
Drake as loud as my speakers would allow
I danced and I ate chocolate this step
is not about problem solving it's about
giving yourself what you need there and
then step 4
hit a mental reset tell yourself that it
sucks but it's ok and it will pass now
that you felt your feelings you can have
mental space again to be rational I've
hung out with the friends who gave me
Drake and chocolate she's cool now it's
time for a friend who helped me solve
the problem what do I need to get done
and how can I make it more manageable
the fifth and last step is simply go
with your head back in the game it's
time to take action
what are your next steps i sat down I
made it to the list
and I wrote remembering why I wanted to
give the speech in the first place now
you might ask why didn't I just suck it
up
I should have sat down and written the
damn thing I could have but my inner
coach is smarter than that and she knows
that if she forces me to do something
the result won't be half as good as when
I'm ready to do it want to do it
self-compassion allowed me to free
myself and be ready sooner whether it's
a bad interview or a bad breakup or
simply a bad day you want to pick
yourself up faster so you're ready for
whatever life throws at your next Coach
K lives by the next play philosophy
whatever you've just done is not nearly
as important as we're going to do right
now as he says anyone who's had success
or wants it can have a rear view mirror
in their car they can't look back
they've got to look ahead so don't look
back be a good coach to yourself show
yourself some self compassion name it
feel it comfort yourself reset go five
steps you got this I believe in you
[Applause]
[Music]